نعم غنوه ارتفع عدد الشهداء نتيجه قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف منزلا لعائله الزاملي شرق
مدينه رفح الى 19 شهيدا معظم الشهداء
الذين وصلوا الى مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار
نتيجه هذا القصف الذي استهدف المنزل
الماهول بالسكان ودون سابق انذار وفي
ساعات الليل المتاخره هم من الاطفال
والنساء الى جانب العشرات من الاصابات
نتيجه هذا القصف الذي دمر المنزل على رؤوس
ساكنيه تدميرا كاملا وايضا الحق اضرار
ماديه كبيره في منازل المواطنين المجاوره
لهذا المنزل المستهدف بينما فرق الانقاذ
لازالت تعمل على انتشال جثامين عدد من
الشهداء لازالوا حتى هذه اللحظه بين ركام
هذا المنزل الذي استهدفته الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه بعدد من الصواريخ
فيما تكافح فرق الانقاذ وايضا الاطباء في
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار لانقاذ حياه
العديد من المصابين الذين وصلوا الى
المستشفى وهم مصابون بجروح خطيره وسط
امكانيات محدوده يعاني منها هذا المستشفى
الرئيسي في مدينه رفح وهو
مستشفى كان يعد مركزا صحيا بالاضافه الى
ان الغارات الجويه والقصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي يتواصل هنا على مدينه خانيونس
ويستهدف المناطق الشرقيه من المدينه كما
شن الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي عده غارات
جويه استهدفت منطقتي قيزان النجار وبطن
السمين الى الجنوب الشرقي من مدينه
خانيونس وايضا يسمع في محيط كليه العلوم
والتكنولوجيا في منطقه قيزان الجار دوي
اشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما ان الدبابات
الاسرائيليه والاليات العسكريه المتوغلة
مينه خان يونس تطلق بين الفين والاخرى
اسلحتها الرشاشه تجاه عدد من المناطق
والاحياء السكنيه في تلك المنطقه والبوارج
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا تطلق قذائفها
اتجاه الساحل الغربي لمدينه خانيونس فيما
يتواصل القصف المدفعي وايضا الاشتباكات في
الاطراف الشرقيه لمخيم البريج والمغازي
بالاضافه الى القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي
والتوغل الاسرائيلي في المحور الشمالي من
مخيم النصيرات وسط القطاع